[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys and
welcome back to the leia hill pen show
it is always
powered by icon plus so really quickly
for you so this year icon will make a
strong push into stos if you don't know
those are security token offerings it
will fully utilize the ics token
and have synergies with icons d5
services and its interoperability
protocol
always great news from icon there um and
this show as you know is sponsored by
block five so a quick shout out to them
i use them to earn up to eight point six
percent
um interest on my uscc so that is pretty
insane you can also get um i think it's
up to
250 dollars i'm depending on how much
you deposit so i'm going to leave um
the link for that in the description and
in the comment section and
before i bring on my really cool guest
uh also it is sponsored by
coinflips so you can get 10 off
transactions if you use the code which i
believe is scrolling somewhere at the
bottom
so before i bring my guests on if you
are watching on youtube then please
don't forget to
hit the like button and hit subscribe so
you never miss any of these fantastic
guests so
joining me today is the founder of
techcrunch orrington xrp capital which
kind of gives away who it is
he's an entrepreneur a vlogger and a
venture capitalist
it is michael arrington how are you
doing
hello what uh what's coin flip
so they're sponsoring this do i get a
cut of this sponsorship
what's going on with that part of it
damn i i don't think so to be honest but
uh
what is our agreement about it
it's fantastic these companies are um
are sponsoring this kind of content and
uh
i mean on the screen right now which i
don't think everyone sees but i see coin
flip i also see block fi
and and icon so um it's fantastic of
them to be sponsoring this so
although i don't know thank you so much
yesterday
no yeah it doesn't evil doesn't it coin
flip
are um an atm service basically across
the states they have i think it's around
bitcoin atms so with this discount code
you can get
um i think it's around 10 uh 10 off your
transaction so
it's pretty cool isn't it well it
depends are there transaction fees like
because now they're only down to 90 so
it really depends you know what they're
interested in not exactly
no no no no no they're they're a really
good company
they're a solid company so let's do this
yeah we're done i just want to chat to
you now um so for those who don't know
who you are
tell us about yourself um most of us
know who you are but just
go for it uh i you know i don't like
this part
uh why like well because like you i grew
up
interviewing other people um sorry about
that beeping that'll stop
but um so i don't like talking about
myself as much
and uh but i'll do it but i don't like
it and
um i don't know but i i've always been
an entrepreneur
well actually i started off as a lawyer
in silicon valley and um
and then i left that and joined one of
my startups and then started my own
companies after that most of them didn't
do much that was interesting but i did
finally start a company called
techcrunch
that um was both commercially and
culturally successful and that that kind
of
changed my career a little bit and uh
and that was started in 2005
and i sold it in 2010 and uh techcrunch
is still going strong and it's good to
see that
um but after that i started a a venture
fund i did traditional venture investing
i did that for uh i don't know seven
years or so
and i got a little bored with that
although i still do some of it and then
i got into crypto
and now i have a crypto hedge fund and
it's called arrington xrp capital
nice so we're going to go through all of
that
but now everybody knows what you do but
before we go into it
you know it's been hectic on social
media at the moment
um you know we connected through social
media social media is is really just
like this
godsend which has transformed everything
you know given this pandemic we have it
really is a bit of a godsend but
i just want to get your views on
everything that's going on you know in
terms of social media censorship
um you know trump being the platforms
while he was the sitting president what
are your thoughts on all of this
so we're just jumping right into
politics yeah let's do it we're going to
go back to techcrunch i just want
because we've got to talk the most
recent yeah this is hot this is fire
you know people want to hear the fire
let's do it the fire i don't know if i
have a lot of fire i
i spoke out a lot about censorship over
the last
month or two i'm not a trump voter but
i think that he's been treated very
badly on the way out
and um and i think it's dangerous what
we're doing to trump voters in the u.s
um by calling them basically all
terrorists and nazis i think is
actually encouraging erratic and uh
behavior so i think it's generally a bad
thing and i've spoken up on that but i
also think it's becoming more and more
dangerous to talk about this
and i don't mean it like you know police
are going to start knocking on my door
any second
because i say i'm against censorship but
i think it's just becoming not smart to
do it and
i'm a libertarian i strongly believe
in the right to free speech i strongly
believe in the right to bear arms
and um those aren't popular positions to
hold anymore and i'm not sure
it makes much sense to really fight
those battles at this point i think it
makes more sense to focus on family
and and making individual
decisions that are the best for yourself
in other words i think we're entering a
period of darkness
uh in the west and i think that period
of darkness will go on for a while
so i absolutely um agree with you um
i think it's kind of i think it's kind
of sad that we're at a point whereby we
sort of feel a bit um apathetic towards
it
in terms of sort of saying um you think
it's a dangerous move to
to speak up about it i hear you and i
feel that
just because um a lot of a lot of let's
let's call them conservative leaning
accounts have lost
thousands and thousands um you know
friends of mine have lost over 20 000
followers this week
um and even my account which isn't that
political i don't think if someone could
tell me otherwise
a little bit okay you do it in code
sometimes but yeah you clearly have
politics so yeah that's funny encode
that's jokes
um i like that um but yeah you know i i
lost about 600 um i was about 600
followers um
and like it is and you know you work so
hard to sort of like
build well listen you work so hard to
build something
but then say that again i'm making fun
of you like look i mean look
i know there's a lot of bots on twitter
and
those bots are up to all kinds of stuff
uh every once in a while followers sort
of vaporizing groups
i think that you have a strong core
audience and it will get bigger over
time as you create
great content so i wouldn't worry about
600 followers a whole lot
um no i know i mean i think it's just
the grand scheme like people lost over
20 000 followers and
you know i just think it it's concerning
us you know like you said because
you sort of feel it's dangerous i mean i
think it was aoc who sort of said these
people should be put on a list right
these um trump supporters should be put
on a list so
yeah yeah yeah it's it's terrible it's
dangerous it's awful a lot of those
accounts are bots that probably doesn't
matter if they're there or not but a lot
of real people are getting silenced
and for speech that is not in any way
illegal at least in the united states
the uk has
significantly different laws around this
and it's always unclear to me what's
legal in an illegal speech
in the uk um and i know you're
i i think you've been very public about
the fact that you'd like to leave the uk
at some point
um i uh i'm worried about it
but like i said there's only you know
there's only so much we can do
but i will also say this i'm not a trump
supporter so it actually is a bit of a
relief to have him gone
and and part of that is it's too bad
part of it is because the media hated
him the media created him
and the creator the media destroyed him
and so i'm just as mad at the media as i
am at trump
but the whole thing was just a total
show and it
to some extent i'm glad that part at
least is over
and that we can move on from that but i
think that what we're doing now instead
of trump the trump show
is actually significantly more dangerous
yeah i totally agree with you because i
think at least with trump we sort of
understood
and i say we because when america
sneezes the whole world catches the cold
um you know so when elisa trump we know
what we're getting i happen to think
with somebody like biden and kamala
harris
it's kind of um i don't think they're
sort of
clean and and i don't think their
intentions are as pure and i think
that's actually more
dangerous um i mean what's pretty
interesting is the whole idea of like um
a woman of color and particularly a
woman being the first
um being the first vice president and
then the media tell us not to focus on
these things
but biden openly said that's the reason
why he hired her right like he said
that yeah it's a mess
so what do we do we just focus on family
well that's what i'm doing like i
i i think um
i've tried everything i've tried back in
the day i tried financially supporting
politicians i actually don't think i've
ever given money to a republican
but i gave money to cory booker and i've
given money to
other politicians in the u.s and this is
you can actually search all this stuff
and see who's donated to who
um cory booker turned out to be a total
disaster i mean he used to like he
didn't understand
i don't know him when was it he's uh he
ran cory booker ran
for president he's a senator from new
jersey um
he's um oh he's dating the main thing
everybody knows before now is he's
dating that
famous actress is it rosario dawson is
that anyway
he um but he turned into like uh a
totally
like down the middle politician to like
this crazy eyes guy
who literally crazy eyes who um who says
all kinds of like nutty things and i
regret ever giving money to him like i
was just trying to support politicians
that i thought could be
sane and i'm not sure there are any
anymore and so
i'm not making any more political
donations i think it's pointless to
speak out on social media about this
stuff because at best you're ignored at
worst you're
deleted from the internet and i think
it's just better for
everyone to sort of focus on what's
happening in the world and that's where
i think is interesting because
if you put aside the like civil rights
issues
freedom of speech etc and you look at
what's happening
in the financial world there's a lot you
can do to protect yourself i think from
what these governments are doing
uh to keep themselves in power which is
spend spend spend
print print print and that's where i
think that those of us in crypto
are in a really interesting place right
now where we can protect our families
and protect our futures
um while we wait through this sort of
this period of darkness that i believe
you know really can't be fixed um in the
short term
yeah i absolutely agree i think it is a
period of darkness and
for that reason i'm like so honored and
i feel so privileged to be in crypto
um because i really i know people say
bitcoin fixes this and that's just some
cliche
rubbish which kind of has like a tiny
bit of truth to it but
it really is sort of like an opportunity
to opt out and i think
i absolutely yeah did you just call
bitcoin a
cliche and rubbish no i called bitcoin
fixes this
the slogan cliche and not entirely 100
accurate
but it does fix me it fixes some things
it doesn't fix everything is it going to
fix people taking away your right to
bear arms
no is it going to is it going to fix um
there's so many things that people know
bitcoin
um but what you can do is
in my opinion i tweeted this out the
other day i think i've got some backlash
for it but just
make enough money so that you can
literally just leave
like leave go to place leave the west go
to places where
um you know there isn't this like
looming communism
for which i sort of feel is coming or
oppression awareness
so where do you think what two questions
on that one
you're not a us citizen i assume uh and
so
you're not like you know u.s citizens
are particularly screwed because we
can't we can leave the u.s but we can't
leave the u.s tax system and we're the
only ones
fascinating until recently by the way
that you always have to pay tax
no that's why you don't see a lot of
americans working in dubai
and singapore and other tax havens
because there's absolutely no point i
mean they might go there there are some
but if you live in the uk you can go to
dubai or singapore or wherever
and sometimes pay little or no tax on
your income
in the us you still pay your your tax
back home including your state tax if
you if you've just moved from a state
that has a lot of taxes so that's you
know we're just we're tax donkeys so
we can't get away from that now you can
of course just leave the country if you
think it's a good time to leave
um but i envy you the ability to
sort of hop around the world with a with
a great passport
but not have to worry about whatever
taxes are hitting you back home and only
worry about the taxes of the
of the place you actually live that's
really interesting
um to just on that point i look i cannot
name names but i know a guy who is
american
um and he's just often his thing and
he's not paying
those uh those u.s tax he's he's never
he's never even lived in the states
but uh i think it's the irs is sort of
like banging on his door and he's having
an issue he's like
i live he's like i was just born there
for two minutes i've lived in the uk or
wherever else he's lived all his life
who is this you're talking about i can't
say you can't i can't think so the irs
will
go after him i can't say it's just a guy
i know he he you know he's just
running he said the irs is already
banging on his door so
well not literally but they're emailing
him they're getting his number
they're you know they're trying to get
hold of him yeah okay well anyway there
is there is
one way as an american citizen to get
around u.s taxes and that's to move to
puerto rico
and that loophole is still open and as
far as i know it is the only legal way
to avoid
u.s taxes as a u.s citizen as you move
to puerto rico you spend at least i
don't know six months a year there
and that's why a lot of crypto people
there like brock pierce and others have
moved there
um to avoid u.s taxes um but that's it
and then you have to live in puerto rico
which has you know it's good and bad
so so how did you get into crypto
so i've got xrp in the uh in the
uh in the co in the what's it called the
description of the of the video so
let's talk about crypto i do want to get
to techcrunch in a bit but how did you
since we're on the crypto topic how did
you get into crypto
well i being in silicon valley you're
kind of crypto adjacent anyway
um you know we're obviously were hyper
aware of bitcoin
even 10 years ago um
and eth when it first came out and was
raising money
um and we made we being my partner and i
my venture fund made some bets in crypto
um
and those bets are starting to you know
become liquid now but those were not
tokens those were
those were just equity you know equity
and things like coinbase although i
didn't invest in coinbase i didn't have
the opportunity to
um i did buy bitcoin and i think 2013
was the first time i bought it and i
think that was
when it was coinbase and uh
you know so i've held bitcoin since then
um and i bought eth very early
but again i wasn't in the crypto i was
still looking for the next ubers and
those kinds of companies that we
invested in in 2017 though
a lot of people got into crypto in 2017.
um
during the ico boom i started to take a
much harder look at crypto
and that's when i decided after doing a
couple of deals that i'd like to do it
full-time
okay and so at that point that also is
yxrp at that point i started thinking
about raising a fund
and i just knew the xrp people very well
because they're based in san francisco
and i'd known them
for a while and so i approached them
about
helping me raise that fund and that's
sort of how it all started
and ripple didn't
actually become an lp in the fund but
they introduced me to people that did
become lps in the fund so i owe a lot to
them
for helping me get this fund off the
ground and that's sort of how it all
started
but why specifically xrp though as
opposed to
any other sort of asset i knew i knew
people who had large amounts of capital
in xrp
and they became my initial lps now
what's interesting is at first i wasn't
going to call it
arrington xrp capital i was just going
to call it something you know my last my
venture phone was named crunchbond like
i was going to call it something
and actually the ripple people who
aren't directly involved
actually weren't like super excited
about me calling xrp because
you know it was just unclear if i was
going to be associated with them
you know legally because of that name
but i kind of pushed because i wanted it
to be called xrp capital and so they
said okay it's fine it's actually not a
trademark go ahead and do it
and um and so it you know that that's
how that happened
and since then our lps are not
necessarily xrp holders but that's a
legacy
issue that has stayed with us and we
remain
extremely loyal to the xrp community and
ripple as a company
so xrp is such a hot topic um
all the time um and i saw one of your
interviews i think you did with pomp and
you were sort of talking
about like the tribalism and things like
that so tell me about
the tribalism that you felt you know
particularly just having
xrp in the name
yeah it it surprised me so when i
entered crypto
again i was adjacent to crypto in tech i
understood a little bit about what
crypto was happening the tech side more
so
what i wasn't ready for was the
tribalism and
i i mean i kind of ran face first
into a wall when i announced the fund
on stage at coindesk and i think
november late november 2017
and suddenly there were people who loved
me who i didn't know
because i was doing an xrp denominated
fund
and there are people who truly hated me
and wanted me truly dead because i was
doing an xrp denominated fund
and i'd never seen that before like i'd
see in tech i'd seen people like apple
versus
windows type stuff before but never that
kind of tribalism
and it's taken me a few years to figure
it out because it's not very logical
like
it doesn't make a lot of sense to hate
xrp
because it's structured differently than
bitcoin or e
until you really get into the
philosophies involved in
bitcoin and ethan and everything else
and so everybody in crypto hates each
other but everyone in crypto
also agrees they hate xrp and so that
yes that has been like the one sort of
common theme that brings everyone
together is we all hate xrp
i think that's ridiculous and i've said
why a million times
but it was surprising and it continues
to some extent
and it's annoying and it's sort of a
friction
and that it is what it is so yeah i
think
um i i tweeted out um maybe back in like
september
last year i wrote you know imagine
hating somebody because they prefer a
different coin to you
and um adam back who's well known to be
um you know
potentially satoshi uh-huh you know
obviously somebody very much in the
bitcoin um faction um he sort of said
imagine supporting a ponzi scheme um but
not just about exit that wasn't just
directed at xrp is directed to the east
was directed at um
eos as directed at um i uh
pretty much all all of them and i i can
remember the founders sort of came
running in sort of saying wow i've lost
a lot of respect for you
for calling you know me a ponzi scheme
yeah i mean yeah that's every day that's
twitter that's crypto twitter and i
think it drives a lot of people away
they don't want to get burned right so
they don't want to touch the
hot fire and and that's too bad because
it would be nice if we could have some
philosophical differences but still
agree on some core set of principles but
we aren't there yet
um and i don't know what do you think
those philosophical differences are
the differences or what are the things
that could bring us together
no like those philosophical differences
do you because i sort of think it's
there's like a libertarian undertone
which sort of differentiates the two and
what do you think
differences yeah
why do people hate different coins is
that what you're asking no no between
bitcoin
and xrp i sort of feel like they're the
antithesis of each other
oh i think bitcoin and dollars are the
antithesis of each other i think that um
i mean you have bitcoin going this way
dollars going this way i think you know
bitcoin and xrp is more like this
in terms of the angle but look i mean
xrp
is a ledger based currency and
it is just the way that consensus is
reached
is much different than bitcoin and
because of that difference
people feel that xrp is more centralized
and because of that they feel the xrp is
censorable
mutable etc whether that's true or not
becomes irrelevant because this becomes
a religious war and facts become
irrelevant
uh i love bitcoin i have said and
believed that bitcoin is the alpha and
the omega it is you know
it is the sun and the moon and my it is
the most perfect
money ever invented or or even thought
of
um i also think that eath is a very
important currency
and and i believe the world computer
narrative and i think that it is
exceptionally interesting and important
plays a role in bitcoin cannot and
should not play and i think xrp
does the same as do other coins and so i
have no fundamental
uh desire for xrp to die of fiery death
simply because it is in some instances
less decentralized than bitcoin for the
same reason i don't want eth to die
um because it is a totally different
currency than bitcoin and say has more
inflation
yeah i understand so essentially they
all you know have
value in different ways um
but in terms of what happened with the
sec i want to get your thoughts on that
because
that for some came out of the blue for a
brad garland house apparently
it didn't quite come out the blue um so
what are your thoughts on that
um do you think it's a security and also
like how would you define a security for
those that don't know
this is xrp obviously yeah yeah you just
asked a lot
i okay so
let's start with defining a security
let's start with defining a security if
you can
yeah okay well so i hate this question
and i'll tell you why like i like
answering it but i hate the question so
i actually was a securities lawyer
before i became an entrepreneur that was
back a ways but i wrote a book about
initial public offerings
i can't i knew i know securities law and
whether or not something is a security
even asking that question just plays
into the hands of the sec
they want everybody using their
definitions to decide what isn't isn't
uh a security look we buy
cryptocurrencies with the hope of making
money when they're denominated
in dollars we do that because we don't
believe in dollars anymore
is that a security uh maybe i don't know
it depends because it's not it's not
just about
is it a security and then the
conversation's over it's is it a
security
and then if it is which is entirely a
legal definition
then the sec can really put the hurt on
you
and so i think it's all securities in
the sense of like we're all buying these
things because we're trying to get into
assets that will protect us
from what the dollar is doing but no are
we looking at the howie test a hundred
year old sort of test that is absolutely
useless in a modern world
it's ridiculous and so we also have to
look at the fact that there's like seven
other
federal organizations that are
that are regulating crypto and so is it
a currency is it a commodity
how does the irs tax it how does the doj
and the fbi
look at all of this and it's just a mess
and so what is more interesting than is
this a security how do we define a
security is
will the u.s come up with a coherent
regulatory scheme
that allows americans and people who
want to do business in america
to experiment with new business models
and new type of assets
to compete on a worldwide basis and the
answer so far is absolutely not the us
is only concerned with how to tax it and
how to shut it down
and so we need to fix those two problems
from a much higher perspective than
is this a security or not a security
does that answer the question yes kind
of
um but from you know i think it was a
wonderful
answer to the question but i still well
well not exactly because you didn't
answer like
do you think it's a security because it
matters it matters because although you
said although you said you know we
should be focusing on other issues
like the fact that they're sort of
stifling innovation through all this tax
and this and that
um but you know as as you know the
founder of arrington xrp capital there
are a lot of xlp bag holders watching
now
a lot of people sort of feel that you
know this could give xrp clarity
so um that matters as well the d listing
of xrp on many different platforms
matters just really about you know for
people holding xrp foreign you don't
want to talk philosophy you want to talk
like
down and dirty like what's actually
going to happen here and i don't have
the answers
i have no idea like yeah i mean
exchanges are delisting xrp
despite the massive volume of xrp trades
that were happening and a lot of fees
they're creating because they're scared
they're scared of the us government and
so you saw a nasty listing which is you
know that's
it's not that surprising um when it
comes to like what what's actually going
to happen which i think is what you're
really
the future is what i'd like to know look
i'm hoping
that we get some regulatory clarity from
this but what i believe is the sec
wants ripple dead to put a feather in
their cap um
now that's pure speculation
based on nothing other than speculation
also the sec
is an entity that changes over time and
is changing right now in terms of sec
chairs and so what the sec wants over
time is largely going to be dependent on
what the executive branch wants over
time
and the executive branch just changed so
i have no idea i have no visibility into
what's going to happen in xrp at all
i believe the sec probably wants us to
go to trial and with those to trial
we'll see what happens
um but i don't know and do i think it's
a security from the point of view of the
sec no
but from the point of view of me it just
doesn't matter like
what's a security what is it security is
totally irrelevant
and it really just comes down to like
whether you only allow rich people to
trade an asset you allow
everybody to trade an asset and so when
you look at like things like uber i was
able to
invest in one of the first rounds of
uber and airbnb
and pinterest because i had wealth and
had a venture fund
everyday people who are just as smart or
smarter than me
also wanted to invest in those companies
or would have if they could have like
looked at the business plans like i did
but the government told them that
they're not worthy that they're too poor
and so they can't make good financial
decisions on their own and so they're
not allowed to invest in that
and so they don't get to make 10 000 x
returns on things like
uber and pinterest and airbnb and other
companies doordash is actually a funny
one because i said no to it but all my
friends became multi-billionaires on
doordash
so now it's the same damn thing the sec
comes in and they say we don't want
we don't think poor people their
definition of poor are smart enough to
make decisions
the rich people are and so we're going
to stop them from doing that
that's evil and so who cares what the
definition of a security is at the end
of the day
and we can debate that all day although
i'd probably just tune out at some point
because i don't care
what i do care about is that we should
stop fraud
and we should allow people to make any
decisions that they want to make
financially speaking
and that's it and that's the end of the
conversation from my point of view
because i'm only looking at it
philosophically okay so philosophically
speaking
um you know if this does hurt xrp do you
think this is therefore a threat to the
rest of the crypto space
that the question you just asked god
you're you're good at this the question
you just asked
is um is can anything take
crypto down at this point right that's
really the question you asked
so xrp is decided there's a security
it's decided by court that there were
there were securities sold
without an exemption or registration
under the securities act
and everybody that works or ever worked
for ripple is now imprisoned for life or
put to death why not do that
what happens then i i think it's bad for
crypto but
i think that crypto lives lives on and
um but i don't know what that means for
example let's say that tomorrow the
united states government said that
bitcoin is a national security threat
across the board every regulatory agency
said we're not allowing bitcoin it's
illegal now
congress passes a law if you hold
bitcoin you're gonna be put to death
done would that kill bitcoin
no but it would suck and it would be de
facto dead anyway because you know
people would have to decide if they want
to hold this asset and be put to death
so i think the u.s government has a has
the ability to kill crypto
but i don't know i think as more and
more time goes on and more and more
government representatives own crypto
that becomes a less a smaller and
smaller likelihood
but no i don't think i don't think xrp
whether xrp lives or dies has
much effect on crypto in general
but what's right and wrong it matters a
lot
yeah i think i think it's kind of that
last bit which which kind of gets me i
think
what's right and wrong absolutely does
matter and whether you can sort of take
down something which is decentralized
um i don't think it's possible but in
terms of um
heavy regulation taxing every single
move that you make
i think that's sort of what will make
things harder like in the uk for example
they're very anti-crypto here and
we've had a lot of issues with banks and
for me it's so hard just to use things
let's say like um
like crypto.com it's really hard to use
um being uk based what's what's
crypto.com
is that another spot i don't know who
that is no they're not a sponsor no no
no i'm
completely they don't sponsor the show
i'm very transparent with everything
um no i use them they're a debit card
they're an exchange
and essentially um i can send money well
i can't now i used to be able to send
my pounds into um intercrypto.com
whereas now i can't they've completely
destroyed
that um because you're big gateway so i
can get my words out
no it's just more you um no not the bank
it's just a wider regulatory issue
um in the in the uk um so i have to use
something like revolut
and then convert to euros and then send
the euros in but converting let's just
say you want to convert like
you wanna feel like let's say um 10
grand or whatever it is
converting that from euros to pounds
is gonna be a lot in terms of like the
exchange fees and whatever it is so
that's the kind of regulation that i
think yeah
is more scary um well okay on the other
hand look i think that sucks and
and it's terrible on the other hand
these gateways and these
this friction that banks and governments
are creating is
is probably stopping bitcoin and crypto
from becoming an
overheated bubble some people say it's a
bubble now we don't believe it
is in any way so yeah it sucks but in
the long run
these gateways and this friction might
actually help the market sort of be a
little bit more steady
um otherwise you might have seen bitcoin
go to a hundred thousand dollars
you know in the last couple weeks and
and instead we'll see that maybe over
the next couple of years
but yeah but also i don't feel that much
pity for you
because you can get on an airplane and
you can go to dubai
and you can live there in a in a in a
country or a city state
that is actually like pretty pleasant
for large parts of the year and pay no
taxes
i can't do that and so i feel like you
have the better deal
like you can you can go to singapore you
can go wherever the hell you want
and you can pay taxes there that's
pretty good and then you can set up a
bank account wherever it is you just
moved
and those banks are probably much more
open to crypto than they are in the uk
the world's smallest violin is playing
for you right now
yeah yeah i guess so i want to leave the
uk anyway so
i have to figure that one out um but i
want to talk about techcrunch
um because um that has completely i
would say sort of revolutionized um a
lot of different things and the way
um you know the way technology does the
way media
covers technology and so on so this was
something that you did in 2005
so why did you start it just yeah why
did you start it
uh
i mean look there's a it's a mythology
at this point i started it because i had
no job i was surfing i lived in la i
spent my days surfing
and playing video games and eating
burritos
it was pretty good life but i ran out of
money and my girlfriend at the time was
not overly impressed with my lifestyle
and so
i i realized i'd been in and out of tech
i had lived in
in europe for a while i just needed a
reset
and the internet was changing at the
time and it was becoming what
with hindsight is obvious but at the
time was very interesting the read write
web and technologies that allowed you
um to use the internet more like a
desktop
application and so you started to see
things like what has now become like
gmail and like google docs was magic
back then and so you see this sort of
explosion of companies and i just wanted
to get to know those companies
and i started researching them and then
i thought why don't i just post the
research and so if you see the first you
know a few weeks of techcrunch it was
just research being posted without much
like color commentary or personality
but it there was this like uh this
hunger for this kind of news because
there was no positive coverage of
startups at the time like very little
and so people just like like sucked it
in
and it started growing like crazy and
then i just sort of let the business
become what it needed to be
interestingly we're at a similar
position now so there's tons of startup
coverage now
in tech that wasn't didn't exist 15
years ago but it's all gone very
negative and i think that there's
actually like a real cry
for fine negative we hate tech tech is
the cause of all problems that stuff's
fine the new york times can do it all
they want
and even tech crunch to some extent has
become woke crunch and it's less
interesting
but i think that there's a cryo for like
hey people just like yeah yeah we hate
everything but also we'd like to have a
site that just covers tech
in like a positive way as well and that
is verboten right now
but you seem like andreessen horowitz
just recently a couple days ago
decided they're gonna start doing
content that is maybe a little bit more
like raw raw tech which
people are hungry for again and so
there's another just market opportunity
and i
i think that people want that you know
they you need to be critical of tech
when it does evil
but when there's like two women who
start a new company
and they're four days old you don't need
to be super critical of them you just
need to cheerlead them on and hope that
they do well
and then they can raise money and create
a product that people want and like
we don't need to tell them they're evil
and part of the patriarchy and
we just don't at that point and so i
hope that we see more of like what
techcrunch originally was in the future
people clearly want it
so it won't be me though because it's
very hard job like the hardest job
that i've ever had is being a journalist
or a pundit
and having to be creating content every
single day and being on that treadmill
of content creation every single day
was extremely difficult from a health
perspective
and something i will never do again yeah
you talking about just like that news
cycle
yeah waking up like in a panic like what
news did i miss
right and and then and and not going to
sleep because news is still breaking
and you know and then you're not
sleeping well which means you start
gaining weight which means you start
eating improperly
which means you start gaining more
weight which means you're not sleeping
well and so i went from a relatively fit
35 year old to a extremely overweight 40
year old by the time i sold techcrunch
and i don't want to do that anymore so
also it doesn't pay nearly as well as
being an investor
so no journalism is uh
the most one of the most stressful jobs
that pay like
the least i see you right i see how hard
you work behind the scenes you're like a
duck
right like you're floating on the
surface you're this beautiful duck
everything's cool
but like below the seat belt you're like
because i've seen it i've seen you with
trying to schedule me
and like getting you know like it's just
it's a lot of work it was probably
more time getting all this scheduled
with me than we're actually spending now
and then i assume you do some kind of
post editing and all that kind of stuff
too
i don't know but because i've never done
this kind of stuff but it is incredible
the amount of work you do
and i understand why you're doing it
you're building your audience you're
building
your personality and the myth around you
but at some point you probably will want
to do less of that or at least have
teams of people doing it for you
and i hear you firstly i really
appreciate that thank you
um so but the thing is i've actually i
come from a traditional
background of journalism and that was
breaking news and honestly i could never
do that again like that was
torture i used to be in paris and i was
the only correspondent in paris
and that meant it was terrible oh it was
so you lived in paris and yes and it was
just awful
oh yeah classy paris is awful mercy
paris is just terrible sorry if there
are any parisians watching
um absolutely terrible place yeah i had
the
had the the yellow best protesters all
over my road
up and down smashing cart i mean that so
there's that but then because i was the
only
correspondent um i was working
monday to sunday i was working um
from i think i went to barcelona to
cover the catalan the catalonian riots
i was working from six in the morning
until midnight oh my god
yeah i was like you were in paris you
were in paris and you had to go to
barcelona for business
and you had to get up at six in the
morning and work until midnight that
night
happened twice oh my god
you were like what 20 or 23 or something
like that's what you do when you're that
age like
do you know how many people like would
kill to live in paris and be like i have
to go to barcelona to cover something
no not exactly i'll explain why because
okay
i'll explain why um i felt very like
trapped and ball and chained and stuck
basically um so i couldn't do
anything so like i had no um i'm trying
to say i
for example it was okay so my family
wanted to come visit me
i could say no i had to say no
everything i wanted to do i had to say
no
um because if there was like a terrorist
attack for example then i had to go
um i was out at like nine o'clock one
night i had like three glasses of wine
down
and i get um a message that there's um
and there's a hostage situation in
amsterdam and we have to go so i kind of
like had no
i just didn't like the idea that i
couldn't plan things and i had no
control of my life basically
that was the problem i had no control
over enough still that was probably a
great way to spend other than not being
able to see your family and not being
able to drink you know five glasses of
wine before you had to go off to
amsterdam
like it would probably was i like it
experience for you for you to have
right i mean like you know so like i'm
glad i went through the techcrunch
experience i just don't want to repeat
it
that's what i'm saying yeah it's good to
do it like you just don't have i just
like it it completely takes away
any um any um self-determination
honestly
um and control over your life because
you can't you're stuck you're literally
a slave
to the news and i don't want to be a
slave to anything i don't be a slave to
my government i don't be a slave to fiat
currency i don't want to be a slave
to my job i don't want to be a slave to
the news
yeah um so that's kind of that's kind of
the way i see that
um but i had a bunch more questions
um my question was actually um so
in terms of being an entrepreneur
building something so successful what
would you say some of the key
ingredients are
i think the most important thing for an
entrepreneur
to understand is that the entrepreneurs
that ask
other people for advice rarely are
successful
like i just did it i didn't know what i
was doing
and suddenly i was head first into
journalism and journalists were yelling
at me all the time
like crypto but not as bad because there
wasn't money associated with it
but like i never asked anybody for their
advice i never asked anybody what they
think i should do i just did it and so i
think the best entrepreneurs just
do stuff and they figure it out i
never read a business book about you
know how to do business i never i just i
just did it
and um so i don't actually have a lot of
advice for people other than
if you have an itch scratch it like if
there's something you think needs to get
built go for it and that's easier to do
in your 20s
when you don't have a family you don't
have a mortgage in the us you may have
college debt but you don't have a lot of
things stopping you from doing crazy
things
it's much harder when you're in your 30s
and 40s and you have a family it's just
much harder to say yes to something like
that
so do it when you're young because it
costs much less for you personally to do
it and that's it that's my only advice
but what do you think about um so you
said you said you didn't ask or reach
out for help you sort of just
did it but i think reaching out for help
and asking people
is like the most important thing to do
because i feel like that's the issue
we're talking about different things no
no when you need help with a task
networking having people like a support
group that's fine okay what i would what
i meant by that and i didn't say it very
well
is
asking for advice on how to become
successful in business is
in my opinion nearly pointless and
actually suggests you will not be
successful in business
because you're asking other people how
to do it and the whole point of being an
entrepreneur is there's no one way to do
it
and there's no set recipe for being
successful
sometimes you just gotta go and you
gotta fail and you have to learn and you
have to fail some more and you have to
learn
and then suddenly it it will work i
failed
in like three or four startups before
i did techcrunch which wasn't even a
business idea it was a blog it was just
an idea of like networking
and that ended up being where i made my
first chunk of money and so
i didn't i just did it and i actually
talked to friends about it before i did
it including my then business partner
and they're like this is stupid like
nobody
don't create a blog like let's go create
another business so again i'm just not
the guy to ask that kind of advice for
because my only advice is just try stuff
and fail
and good luck i think that people who
are full of business advice
are just like to hear themselves talk
sometimes that's funny um
i think you gave incredible advice
though you just said
keep trying i think that's actually the
most important thing
um because i think there are so many um
people who are number one
too afraid to put themselves out there
because they'll get terrible comments i
mean i don't know if you've seen the
comment section on this interview it's
it's quite something
um so yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm not i don't even know where to look
for the comments the comment section
i've
i've closed it because there it's just a
lot right so you know
that would sort of make some some people
sort of say well i don't want to do an
interview again because you know you get
people hounding at you sort of telling
you
all these sorts of things um what what
comment section are you talking about on
twitter or is there
oh can you not see but if you look to
the right
um yeah i don't know what you can see
because i'm obviously hosting
this um there's a comment section yeah
it's pretty it's pretty wild
it's pretty wild well that's fine yeah
it's fine
yeah you know like it is what it is but
like you know to
something like that sort of would make
people sort of say oh i'm not going to
do that again or i can see you're
reading them now
no i'm not i'm looking this way comments
are that way
don't care yeah okay cool um but no i
think you said the most important thing
i think you have to keep going
there are so many people who are so um
they sort of feel like if somebody says
no or if you fail
then that's sort of you done whereas i i
mean i put out a tweet today and i said
like the most successful people have
failed more times
than those who aren't as successful as
them yeah i mean i
the very first company i started so i
left my
law firm and i joined the company and so
i didn't start that i just joined the
company and i was
doing biz dev and sales for them so put
that company aside it was a cool company
i left that company very immaturely
because they wouldn't
i was like 27 or something they wouldn't
they wouldn't promote me to svp
which was like for more 40 year olds so
i'm like screw you guys and i left
i started my own company and it was a
payments company in 2000
and that company we raised 18 million
dollars in venture capital
and but then in 2000 there the market
fell apart and so
we couldn't raise more money we'd spent
most of it back then it cost a lot of
money
using oracle and stuff to get your apps
up and running today it's all basically
free with
amazon um anyway we sold that company
like 13 months after we founded it
for 33 million dollars and that was on
18 million dollars in venture capital
raised so you think i would have made
some money
but back then venture capital very
standard had a 2x liquidation preference
which meant venture capitalists got
twice the money out before the founders
or anyone else got any money out
two times 18 is 36 million so they
didn't reach their liquidation
preference and the only thing i as a
founder could do was block the sale
so they ended up giving me like 150
dollars to sell the company just to get
my vote because otherwise the company
would have gone out of business
so the company was successful but it
failed from my perspective and i learned
something and then i started another
company and that company just
dead in the water failed and then etc
and so yeah i think that's good and i do
think failure is a necessary part
of being successful um very very few
people
are like bill gates where they just
start their one company in college and
it ends up being massively successful
mark zuckerberg is another example
very few people are like that and i luck
plays a part
um but if you keep trying excuse me if
you keep trying
luck will eventually hit and you will
eventually win
unless you're just terrible at being an
entrepreneur i mean then you may never
be successful
do you think anyone can do it
or some people do not cut out for it
yeah well some people are definitely not
cut out for it is very stressful but
also um
anybody can do it in the us i think in
other countries
you absolutely can't do it the social
stigma of being an entrepreneur in
europe is less than it used to be but
it's pretty significant uk less so
but um maybe that's
maybe that's an age difference i don't
know i've never come across that tell me
no no the idea of failure is a bigger
deal
in europe than it is in the u.s in the
u.s
and europe is like oh you you started a
company and you failed
um also there's french like i have
french friends here that are
friend and friend here being in the u.s
that are french right they've moved here
they become very successful
entrepreneurs sometimes these people
cannot stop talking about their six-car
garage house that they've bought
but when they go to france they said
they will not talk about it and they
they they pre they present themselves as
very humble
and i find that infinitely interesting
as to how they they act one way in the
us
one way in europe but yeah i think
anybody with those caveats i think yeah
anybody can be
more successful um by being more
entrepreneurial even if that just means
being entrepreneurial within your
existing job
i think um you make a really cool sort
of observation
about europeans um because americans is
something that i've noticed because i'm
incredibly european in my in my sort of
um
in my like mentality and behavior and so
on but you guys are just
more extra and more flamboyant and
louder and more excited and more
when it comes to like business you know
like everybody's
because there's like this american dream
right you don't have like the british
dream the english dream it's like the
american dream you know to
to build something and to create and i
feel like you have that there's more
support there and i've noticed that
people um
people definitely you're right people
definitely rally and support
um entrepreneurs a lot more than we do
in the uk because in the uk
you know we're the brits we've got that
stiff upper lip you know we don't want
to rock the boat too much and
to be that entrepreneur you have to do
something different like you did with
techcrunch so
here people don't want to rock the boat
too much you know
it's just a british way i don't i mean i
don't know much about the uk i've lived
there twice we did techcrunch events
there
i love the country i don't know much
about the entrepreneurial mindset there
but some of the best entrepreneurial
entrepreneurs in the world have come out
of the uk i think that europe is a
tougher play and then i think you've got
areas of the world that are so poor and
so lacking in infrastructure and
education
that they no matter it doesn't matter
what the what the
how well entrepreneurs are accepted they
just can't they just can't
break out of that cycle of poverty and
that's terrible um
all right so we're coming up to the end
of the show so i just want to know do
you have any
um okay to make a positive and a
negative number one
what are your sort of things that you're
most proud of your achievements you're
most proud of
and number two do you have any regrets
um
in any of your career so far
um i mean i wish i yeah i mean the
stupid stuff like i wish i had gone all
in on bitcoin in 2010 and just
combining it right it's hard um one
thing that's a little different about my
career as i
i don't understand this so i've seen
people in in silicon valley where i kind
of came out of
it's hard that first that first win is
very hard right so you get to the first
win
and and then what do you do and i what i
don't get is it takes a certain level of
like
aggression to get to that first win and
and risk taking and all that i wrote an
article on tech prince called
are you a pirate that was my most read
article and it's just basically like
entrepreneurs are crazy but you get to
that first level of win and then i see
people
basically they do that the rest of their
life so they found the company they take
it public or they sell it and then they
just
work there or they become a vc and they
start making you know five million
dollars a year and then they just keep
doing that for the rest of their life
i get bored doing that and that's why
like i started techcrunch i was bored
doing other stuff
then i became a vc because i didn't want
to do techcrunch anymore
but after seven years of being a venture
capitalist i was born i mean i was
making more money than i had before but
it was terribly boring because all you
do is you like try to get into hot deals
crypto is a whole new learning
experience for me like i the and it
keeps me young like just learning about
crypto
and so i don't understand why more
people don't want to like constantly try
new things particularly if they've
reached the level of success that allows
them to do that
and and i i don't get it like i don't
get these guys that become
venture capitalists and then they just
do that for 40 years like it's like why
what
you don't get like a bigger private jet
at some point it's just got to be boring
but i think they become
calcified and set in their ways and i
think breaking through that and trying
new things
the whole of your life is is is a much
more interesting way to live
it's a much more interesting way to live
but it's also a much more stressful way
to live
i'm with you like i i'm i'm totally
agreeing with you but i think what i've
sort of
come to realize is that some people that
we're all just different and some people
just like that comfort zone like
they've made enough money like they can
just chill now because you know like you
said
getting that first success or however
you put it um
takes risk it takes aggression it takes
stress it takes blood sweat and tears
yeah why why do that once you've made
millions like just
just chill yeah i i like you know
i don't know why but i don't like doing
that i like i don't know
but i want to keep learning new things
so maybe the next
thing won't be money focused maybe it'll
be like i have a passion for
you know animal welfare and i i could i
could always see myself
getting into that business and trying to
just you know help animals save animals
and um
that probably be me spending money not
making money um
but whatever it is it'll be something
new and i'll probably learn some new
things and i think everybody should be
curious about that
if you if you have it in you if you
don't then you know find happiness your
own way because there's probably lots of
ways to be happy
in this life so just lastly then
um tech has moved a huge way
since 2005 when you started techcrunch
you know we're talking about uh
cryptocurrencies i mean that's just
insane so um firstly did you expect
it to sort of really just explode the
way it did and then secondly
where do you expect you know how do you
expect it to look in 10 years i thought
you're going to hate that question but
let's talk about crypto what i didn't
quite understand the tag just tech in
general technology like
you know social media crypto all of it
it's just exploding in every possible
way so did you expect that
um oh yeah i expected look if you if you
look at
tech from a from a fundamental
standpoint you've got
you've got you got microchip like
processing speeds and you have
data bandwidth and so we're doing a good
job of getting data like
bandwidth speeds up around the world um
but it still could be so much
better and chip processing speeds have
largely plateaued
in any real way and until there's a
major breakthrough
we're not going to see like the next
level of stuff that is truly magic i
mean if you'd shown an iphone to
somebody 100 years ago
they would be their brain would explode
because it looks like magic to them
what is what's the thing that they could
be shown to us today that would make our
brains explode and you can imagine what
those things are like fully immersive
um virtual reality you know
uh okay 3d printing teleportation would
make
a lot of changes the destruction of the
soul so i'm not a big fan of
teleportation from a star trek
perspective but
yes these kinds of things where are we
like
we need like is that like are we going
to slow down it's like the kind of
innovation we're seeing in 10-year
period now is we're going to see over
100 year period in the future
and that just comes down to whether or
not we see scientific breakthroughs that
can keep up with
our expectations and that's way out of
my area of expertise but i've been
funding
some companies that are doing pure
science and and i hope that
i hope that we continue to see gains
there that can help us in other areas
nice so any last words before we uh
before we sign off and say thank you to
our viewers we've got a lot of views i
i'm a big fan of yours i don't know
exactly when i started following you
but uh ever since then which was
sometime early last year i think you
know i just
enjoy you know listening to you on on
your podcast and reading you on twitter
so i'm i'm just honored that you finally
uh agreed to bring me on the show
and uh and if there's anything i can
ever do to help you um you know just let
me know
thanks so much i really appreciate that
i really appreciate that um that
that means a lot kind for someone who's
uh done so much you know so i really
appreciate that so thank you so much for
coming on the show um it's been great um
thank you to my sponsors and thank you
everyone for listening
um if you haven't please subscribe to my
youtube channel and hit the like button
so we can continue to get such brilliant
guests
guys thanks so much bye
[Applause]